the long-term effects of the moment ruin
are hard to know exactly restaurants and
hotels have a long road back that's
clear but what about higher education
the nation's entire college population
is at home right now at exactly the same
moment the economy seems to be heading
south so what effect will that have well
the first thing to know is that whatever
happens next
it will not affect Harvard Yale Stanford
and a handful of schools like those
these places are richer than some
countries they'll be fine no matter what
happens perhaps unfortunately big state
schools are likely to weather the crisis
- they have legislators behind them but
for everyone else on campus this is a
life-changing moment
consider the confluence of factors right
now first endowments are likely to
shrink as the broader economy struggles
donations will drop - for the same
reason that will almost certainly be a
big reduction in students from China a
group whose main appeal has always been
their ability to pay full tuition take
that money off the ledger meanwhile and
most critically an entire nation has
just been shown that it's possible to
deliver higher education in an entirely
different way you don't have to drive to
campus buy textbooks pay for room and
board in order to get an education you
can do the whole thing online now this
fact won't change everyone's behavior a
full and finally we'll continue on as
they always have two hundred and fifty
grand to send your kids off of their
friends to have fun for four years two
people who can afford it that's not such
a bad deal it's cheaper than four years
of touring Europe which is what our
ruling class used to do but let's say
you're not rich maybe you make 120 grand
a year that's high enough to disqualify
you from most need-based aid at most
schools but it's low enough that paying
thirty or forty or fifty thousand
dollars a year in tuition hurts a lot if
you're paying full tuition and many
people at that income level are that
means you could be assuming hundreds of
thousands of dollars in debt to send a
single child to college every child
imagine you've got three kids some of
you watching don't need to imagine that
because that's you suddenly an online
education doesn't sound so crazy your
kids won't like it as much hanging
around a fraternity is a lot more fun
than studying on a computer screen but
so what and actually is that a downside
you might start thinking about that
you might also begin to wonder what a
college degree is worth these days an
engineering degree from say Caltech will
always have value medical school or law
school might be worth it under some
circumstances but a communications
degree from a mid-tier liberal arts
school totally and utterly worthless
maybe less than worthless since it
signifies such obvious mediocrity
colleges know all this of course they
know their value
they've been bleeding the middle-class
dry for decades and they're self-aware
enough to realize it and that is why
Washington is swarming with higher ed
lobbyists so that Congress will keep
funding this charade as long as possible
well the impossible may have just
arrived the charade is exposed Stanford
University just kick students off campus
and moved its operations online that's
happening in a lot of places but here's
the amazing part Stanford along with
Harvard and some other schools like them
has already announced that students will
not get a single cent discounted from
their tuition
despite being denied everything that
makes an expensive College expensive
even more insulting and baffling really
Stanford students aren't even being
fully refunded rent for the dorm rooms
that were kicked out of keep in mind
that Stanford has a twenty seven billion
dollar endowment they could afford to do
this for their kids they just don't want
to because they're pampered and arrogant
and indifferent to the suffering of
others as noted Stanford and Harvard and
Yale and Princeton all have enough
cachet to get away with things like this
but other schools don't unless they
change radically a lot of these places
are likely to go under in coming years
there is not enough federal bailout
money in the Treasury to save every
pointless university in a bad recession
they will be gone for good
closed repurposed we can hope into
much-needed efficiency apartments with
loads of appealing green space countless
Dean's of diversity and inclusion will
be out of work
they'll wail and moan and they'll write
outraged editorials in the New York
Times about the end of knowledge in the
coming Dark Age yeah
ignore them these people never deserve
jobs in the first place the higher
education establishment is hurting this
country and has for a long time reform
is essential this is a good and needed
thing in fact it's one of the few bright
spots in an otherwise dark moment